deep learning laptop
it sounds like an oxymoron to me so when
Lambda reached out to me excited to
share with me their latest tensor book a
laptop for doing deep learning I was
pretty curious to check it out this
latest version tensor book is
essentially a maxed out razor blade
laptop and these Razer Blade laptops
tend to be geared more so to Gamers but
as is often the case especially with
entry-level deep learning machines the
specs between a gaming machine and a
deep learning machine can often be very
similar if not identical Lambda also
sent me their previous model tensor book
which has the same specs but a different
chassis so I'll be comparing to that as
well as previous laptops that I've
personally owned over the years laptops
I can find online in my current laptop
the MacBook Pro inside the laptop we
have an 80 watt hour battery two one
terabyte nvme drives for storage 64
gigabytes of RAM which is pretty hefty
for a laptop the CPU is an 8 core Intel
i7 11 800 H and the GPU the Crown Jewel
of the laptop is a 3080 Max Q now if
you're like me you have no idea what a
Max Q is and what does that mean how
does this thing actually perform
compared to desktop gpus that we're
familiar with I've run my own deep
learning Benchmark here it's the same
one that I've used to test other desktop
gpus and workstations and all that it's
essentially a training and fitment task
so in this chart smaller is better it
indicates a faster processing time for
that training so the 3080 Max Q GPU is
12 percent faster than a 1080 TI and a
desktop build it also has 16 gigabytes
of memory versus the 11 in the 1080 TI
now you might be wondering though wait a
second why are we comparing this to a
1080 TI this is a 3080. should shouldn't
we be comparing it to a 3090 or a 3070
and this is where the strange Nvidia
nomenclature enters the chat and uh it
can get kind of confusing but these
these laptop gpus this laptop 3080 Max Q
uh is not comparable to a desktop 3080.
furthermore it gets even more absurd
when you compare this to something like
the a6000 there are laptops with an
a6000 in them but that a6000 is a it has
16 gigabytes of memory versus the
desktop a6000 which has 48 gigabytes of
GPU memory also that a6000 is a an
incredible GPU extremely powerful GPU
the laptop version the again a6000
laptop version is 16 gigabytes of memory
and at least from everything that I can
find and then also I was asked asking
the people at Lambda hey why don't you
guys do the a6000 and they're the ones
that were like well actually the a6000
let me tell you
um it seems like it's the same chip and
or very very similar chip so it's not
actually any significant performance
increase over the 3080 Max q and then
also it's the same amount of memory it's
basically the same chip it's really
weird what they're doing there I feel
like nobody in their right mind would
buy one of these a6000 laptops if they
fully understood
like the only reason you would buy an
a6000 laptop in my humble opinion is you
have been misled
and I don't know that it's your fault so
with that in mind the 3080 Max Q is
essentially the best laptop GPU that
money can buy right now you might be
able to actually get a little more
performance if you do get one of those
a6000 laptop gpus I would really love to
like test one and really see because it
seems like in my opinion it just seems
like like people are confused about what
actually is that GPU and uh it seems to
be priced like it's an a6000 in a laptop
but it is simply from what I can tell
not next let's talk thermals first by
comparing this Razer Blade laptop to a
more generic laptop and I'm going to
actually compare first to the previous
model tensor book because I think that's
the fairest way these are both very high
performance laptops but one's the actual
Razer Blade laptop which has these
things like the vapor chamber and all
that versus a more traditional ish
laptop like the previous model tensor
book but still very high performance
interestingly enough here the latest
tensor book the one that is essentially
a Razer Blade laptop it actually runs a
smidgen hotter than the previous model
tensor book this is also unsurprisingly
true if we'd look specifically at the
GPU itself now these temperature
differences are slight enough to if we
just look a little deeper be explained I
think entirely by the wattages so the
GPU in the latest tensor book is just
simply capable of maxing out that full
80 Watts whereas the previous one just
wasn't getting that full 80 watts and I
think that's really all it takes to to
equal this Delta in temperatures
performance wise we can see the latest
version tensor book does run a little
bit faster in performance and this is
again probably completely described by
the fact that the GPU is just simply
being allowed to pull its full watch
outage so in my research there was Much
Ado made marketing wise about the vapor
chamber in the Razer Blade laptop and
while I think it is very tough to cool
all of these components such that you
could run them all at Full Tilt for
hours on end
um I I don't know that the vapor chamber
is necessarily any better than other
just simple air Cooling and heatsink
type technologies that have existed in
laptops for a while so it's not bad the
cooling is not bad it's just not a major
breakthrough so since this is a laptop
we can also compare powered IE plugged
in performance to battery-only
Performance so when this machine is on
battery power only we see a 24 drop in
at least GPU training performance on
this Benchmark and with that comes lower
wattages and with that comes lower
temperatures but essentially a 24
performance hit when you're just on
battery if you're curious the battery
life not plugged in running at full 100
percent keep in mind the battery pack
itself is an 80 watt hour battery and
the GPU alone wants to take in 80 Watts
it doesn't when it's on battery only but
then when you combine everything else
that's going on it adds up to you might
be able to guess about 80 watts and this
battery does indeed last about an hour
um not plugged in but yet still running
this Benchmark in regular everyday use I
found this laptop battery to be lasting
me anywhere from five to six hours but
this is going to vary hugely depending
on what you're doing how many Tabs are
you have open in your browser and so on
so now on to the i o of the laptop we'll
actually start with the screen itself
it's a 15 inch 1440p
165 Hertz display and I really like it
it's a nice anti-reflective display it
looks great in various lighting
conditions I think this is probably the
thing that is kind of more overboardy
for a data science laptop but we get it
because the chassis is again a gaming
laptop so it's a little more important
in that gaming laptop sector than for
this but no reason we can't enjoy a nice
screen the keyboard is a tkl style
keyboard and I think the thing I like
the most about it is the spacing of the
keys they're not all like bunched in
they didn't try to stuff as many keys as
possible there's no number pads stuffed
in on there and I really like that you
know with a deep learning or a data
science laptop you'd probably see that
number pad and I know lots of people
like the number pad but even when I had
a number pad on my keyboard I never used
it and I have been using a tkl style
keyboard for years now and I just I
really like that and I like the spacing
it's a comfortable laptop keyboard to
actually use but then also to go back
and forth between a desktop and a laptop
I often find I have to get used to like
squishing up my fingers so I so I can
use those keyboards whereas here it
feels it's just natural it doesn't feel
any different than the spacing of any
other keyboard that I have so I really
am definitely a big fan of this keyboard
but keyboards are always super
polarizing uh so I would suggest that
you maybe go try like one of the Razer
Blade laptops somewhere if you have the
ability to and see if you like that
keyboard or not next up a thing that is
often seemingly an afterthought for
laptop manufacturers that is the
touchpad so historically if I went
somewhere with my laptop and I forgot my
mouse it was a sinking feeling in the
chest it was just terrible you know I
there was at least more than one
occasion where I had to go buy a
wireless mouse when I was traveling
because I simply forgot mine when I was
packing
ever since I've owned MacBooks however
I've learned that no a touchpad when
done well and if it's large enough a
touchpad is actually really nice like
you can fully function on a laptop with
just a touchpad and I'm pleased to say
the Razer Blade laptops actually come
with a pretty good sized touch pad it's
got a lot of good software to it I'm
actually really pleased with this and
it's kind of surprising again this is a
meant to be a gaming laptop so the fact
that the touchpad wasn't an afterthought
is surprising honestly but I really
appreciate that so in that way I think
that is one way that this you know razor
blade just in general laptop kind of
begins to be more of a plausible generic
laptop and just a nice laptop to have
for other things besides gaming or data
science and all that so I really like it
it has a lot of the software that you
would expect like a double tap for a
right click or just like a tap and drag
for click and drag you can tap to click
or a long pressing click all that kind
of stuff that you kind of probably
expect in a touchpad if you use them it
does function the only complaint I have
is if you want to press to click you you
the higher up on that touchpad you get
on that Razer Blade laptop the harder
the Press gets to the point where it's
actually pretty hard to press and I wish
that was different at least on the
MacBook that is not that way I don't
know the engineering that would be
required to accomplish that
but just keep that in mind that's
probably my only complaint you could
still you can still tap to click
anywhere on there and it's all the same
it just kind of depends what your habit
and I'm personally in the habit to
actually you know press to click rather
than to tap to click but anyways at the
end of the day that's kind of like my
main qualm and quibble I guess with the
chassis is just I wish that was
different but everything else is so
great that I if that's the only problem
I'm actually pretty happy with that next
up the ports that first Port is the
power our port and you might be thinking
why are we using that over the USBC
Thunderbolt ports so also on this laptop
you do have two USBC Thunderbolt ports
and you can still power the laptop over
those ports the problem is it's not
enough power so this laptop at full load
will still lose power if you're only
powering over USBC slash Thunderbolt the
reason for that is if you have one of
these Chargers it's still only going to
Output 100 to 140 Watts whereas the this
this brick essentially Powers this
laptop at 230 Watts so that's the
difference and that's why you have this
special kind of proprietary looking Port
besides that port and the two
aforementioned USBC Thunderbolt ports we
also have three USB 3.2 ports there's a
full-size HDMI a headphone slash
microphone combo Jack and then also a
full size as SD card reader I think
overall for the ports that's like a 9.5
out of 10 for me the only thing I wish
we still had here is an actual ethernet
port
um I know you can do like a converter or
something like that but I just wish you
had a standard one right here on the on
the laptop we didn't have to think about
it similar to why I still like to have
SD card readers I still use those so I
like to have them but I think eventually
those will be phased out but I also I
think even for like a gaming laptop I
think you still to this day would prefer
to be hardwired over using Wi-Fi so I I
feel like even as the gaming laptop I
think that's probably the only change I
wish there was just have like an actual
Port there there's you have the space
for it just do it that would be my only
change this laptop also does have laptop
speakers and they sound sound like
laptop speakers for fit and finish I
give it like a eight and a half out of
ten I think it's a really good laptop it
is a premium feeling laptop but it
should be at the price tag that it is
which is thirty five hundred dollars uh
this puts you in the realm of MacBooks
and that's what I'm going to compare it
to especially for fit and finish at this
price and for me a Macbook is still kind
of the Pinnacle of fit and finish and
just feeling like a very well-built
machine that I expect to last me a long
time that said MacBooks have had their
problems over the years and there's no
reason to believe necessarily that that
won't continue to be the case or it
won't sometimes be the case for MacBooks
or that this Lambda slash Razer tensor
book thing uh it could be a really great
laptop it could last you for 10 years or
it could not we really don't know one
thing that we do know is that the rate
the Razer Blade laptops have
historically had battery problems now
this has been addressed I believe
multiple times and we will just have to
it remains to be seen whether or not
this will actually be resolved this time
around the problem they've had is just
battery bloat and I think the reason for
that is it's pretty simple these are
high performance laptops they're going
to they're going to have high power draw
and need to have high power back into
the laptop and so on again like I said I
mean we're it's not quite I guess on
average it's probably double the power
input required to those batteries and
then the output for that battery also is
probably double so just the the life of
a battery for a laptop like this is a
hard life
so so I think that's probably why you
have these battery problems with these
laptops also I will say getting to the
battery and like replacing that battery
is not super difficult
um but if you had battery bloat and then
maybe that damaged something else in the
laptop then you got to go through
customer service and that can be quite
the headache especially through Razer if
anything if I was going to buy a buy a
Razer Blade laptop anyways I might just
buy the tensor book just so I can deal
with Lambda instead of dealing with
Razer
so who is this laptop for the price is 3
500 that puts it squarely in the range
of M1 MacBook territory the M1 chip
itself is a better CPU than the CPU
that's in this machine for the M1 Mac if
you want to get 64 gigs of RAM you're
going to have to pay like I think an
extra 400 for that extra 32 gigs
um and then I'm trying to think for
storage I can't remember off the top of
my head with the extra storage will be
but I guarantee it's not coming with two
terabytes at that 3 500 price point so
um spec wise this laptop is better than
an M1 Mac except for the CPU but one
thing it does that the M1 Mac just
simply cannot do or do well is deep
learning now there is marketing that
says you can do deep learning on the M1
Mac and it's great and all that but you
can do deep learning on a Raspberry Pi
that doesn't mean you want to right and
the same thing is true here so so if
you're trying to Dev
um deep learning models and that's
something that you're frequently doing
or not even deep learning just anything
that's GPU accelerated there's a lot of
data science now that is GPU
acceleratable and if you're trying to do
any of that this is a laptop that you
might be interested in but then you
still also have to ask yourself well do
you need this laptop or do you maybe
want to just get a hundred dollar
Chromebook and then shell into a web
server that you're paying far less money
for probably over a period of time so
generally the number I usually go with
is about two to three months if you're
training something for two to three
months you know 24 7 on some Cloud
Server it starts to have made sense that
you maybe should have bought those the
the resources and use them locally but
it depends and right now we are in like
a crazy GPU boom where GPU prices in the
cloud have like halved or even like
thirded I don't know what to call that
but they've got become so cheap so even
from Lambda themselves you can rent an
a100 the most the craziest GPU in the
world you can rent that for a dollar and
ten cents an hour so well 3 500 or 3 400
with your Chromebook
um will go a really long way
um so you have to think like do I
actually need a laptop or can I just use
or do I need a little laptop to be able
to local compute this or could I
theoretically do this
um just connecting into the cloud and I
think that for a lot of people you
probably can just connect to the cloud
and that's totally fine but if you're
someone who is traveling a lot or maybe
you don't want to connect to the Wi-Fi
if you're on the plane a boat car often
depending on where you're traveling
there's lots of reasons why being able
to compute locally on that laptop will
become very important to you and only
you know if that's of importance to you
right so at least for me if I'm on a
plane the I would wish on nobody to
Shell on you know over a plane's Wi-Fi
it's it's the worst so I get that or
maybe you want to do r d and you're
trying to do deep learning with a game
for example something with some sort of
GUI in this case you would still likely
want to be local there's lots of ways
that you could get around this but it's
just it's more tedious and annoying and
then finally I actually kind of think
this is a really good entry-level deep
learning machine because you are going
to outgrow your first deep learning
machine almost no matter what unless you
just quit deep learning and so in this
way when you outgrow this as your main
machine you'll be left with a really
capable laptop right
um and and I don't think you'll regret
it like I've really enjoyed having this
I've had this for a few months now and
when I go out the door I'm not grabbing
my MacBook anymore I'm taking the tensor
book I because it's it's way more
versatile for my needs and I've I've
really enjoyed having that power and I'm
still especially if you're used to
working in Linux it's nice to just
you're in that environment Mac OS is
really close to that but it's just it's
not the same so
um so if you're just trying to get into
deep learning and you're looking for an
entry level uh deep learning machine I
think this is it I mean I generally my
number is about 10 gigs of GPU memory is
enough to like get started you're not
going to be training uh gpt3 or anything
like that at but I would go so far as
and say like I don't know 80 plus
percent of all the Deep learning will
work on this laptop so I think that um
in that way it's it's just a great
entry-level machine
um and it's really versatile it's just
like it's a great entry level machine
for a pretty good price and the cherry
on top is that it happens to be a laptop
right so
for those reasons I mean there could be
other reasons it's just it's really
um kind of like it's up to you if you
really want a laptop uh I think this is
a really good one to look at I I don't
it doesn't look like they're marking
anything up and compared to other other
like deep learning capable we'll say
laptops on the market uh this is priced
really competitively I I would encourage
anybody if if you think you know of a
place where you can get a better price
for this kind of performance post it in
the comments below because I really like
I looked around uh this is really well
priced I don't think that Lambda is
going to make much of anything
monetarily on the laptops I think
they're probably trying to get people
familiar with the brand of Lambda and
hopefully they'll later buy like servers
all right from Lambda or use Lambda
Cloud so
um anyways those are my thoughts on the
uh tensor book and and I think now
finally we're at a point where there
really is a deep learning capable laptop
it exists
and I look forward to the future of
doing deep learning on laptops I hope
one day we really will have the ability
to have something like an a6000 desktop
version in a laptop I think that would
be really cool so I I look forward to
seeing how things go and hopefully
Nvidia will stop naming things the same
as desktop gpus if it does not match the
specs it for the desktop GPU that's
really frustrating
um anyways questions comments concerns
suggestions whatever feel free to leave
those below and I will see you guys in
another video if you're interested in
learning more about neural networks and
how they work then you might want to
check out neural networks from scratch a
book by myself and Daniel kukiwa inside
of which you'll learn how to code
neurons activation functions how to
calculate loss do optimization and back
propagation and of course apply
everything that you've just learned to a
problem the book itself is in full color
for graphs and code syntax highlighting
everything's on high quality pages with
full font and a comfortable line spacing
to make reading easy finally every
concept including the math and coding is
broken down into the a truly atomic
parts and then put back together step by
step to give a full understanding of
neural networks and how they work
including all the math behind them by
the end of the book you will have
created your own neural network
framework from scratch this is the book
that I wish existed when I was learning
to deep learning and I'm extremely happy
to be able to offer it to you if this
sounds interesting to you then you can
head over to
nnfs.io to learn more and buy yourself a
copy